[Music]
road to zero
improving road safety in waimakariri
the waimakariri district is one of the
fastest growing districts in the country
we have roughly 1500 kilometres of roads
that connect our urban and rural
communities
we have a vision for our community
where everyone can get around safely no
matter where and how you travel
road to zero
new zealand's road safety strategy has a
vision that no one is killed or
seriously injured on our roads
it acknowledges that despite our best
efforts crashes will still happen but no
one should be killed or seriously
injured as a result
every person killed or seriously injured
is somebody's family friend or loved one
the impacts of a crash can be
devastating
we all need to work together to make our
community a place where people can get
where they're going safely
whether they're walking cycling
driving riding a motorbike or using
public transport
we have spoken with people in the
community about road safety
listen to their stories in our road to
zero video series and tell us what you
think about the proposed changes to the
speed limits